raymond aron est mort d'une crise
cardiaque cet après midi à paris
philosophe de l'histoire moranis des
journalistes il avait 78 ans l'allemagne
fédérale en pleine fièvre pacifistes
après l'échec de la rencontre entre les
ministres allemand et soviétique des
affaires étrangères
une guerre oubliée l'afghanistan un
document exceptionnel sur le combat des
maquisards afghans le président de la
fédération française de rugby passe
outre les consignes du gouvernement le
quinze de france ira jouer en afrique du
sud
madame monsieur bonsoir raymond aron
n'est plus est d'une certaine manière la
pensée française est veuve veuve de l'un
des esprits les plus aigus de son temps
à la fois essayiste moraliste philosophe
de l'histoire est aussi journaliste il
est mort cet après-midi terrassé par une
crise cardiaque
en sortant du palais de justice de paris
il est mort comme il a vécu en témoin
engagé puisqu'il venait d'aller
témoigner dans un procès en diffamation
en faveur duquel raymond aron a témoigné
à 16h30 raymond aron sens du palais de
justice et succombe à une crise
cardiaque
bertrand de jouvenel apprend alors ferry
- heureusement je sais même pas si je
sais même pas s'ils allaient venir
et puis il est venu puis il a été
éblouissant des bleus y sont il
témoignait en fait des bruits etc et
d'une façon absolument éblouissant
extraordinaire et puis il est parti ce
qui était normal
et puis quand je sors de trois mois je
sors au mehdi ben amor rendez compte de
ce que je peux imaginer et que j'aimais
dit c'est ma faute mais aussi le fait
que pour moi c'est à vous comprenez pour
avoir régné plus d'un demi siècle sur la
pensée française au delà des clivages
politiques et des passions de son temps
pour avoir aussi survécu à jean paul
sartre auquel ils s'opposaient et on
l'opposé souvent raymond aron était de
tous les intellectuels français celui
qui en france comme à l'étranger
perpétuer en tout luminosité une
certaine tradition de l'intelligence
française
on l'avait vu encore il ya moins d'un
mois quand bernard pivot lui consacrait
un numéro d' apostrophes à l'occasion de
la publication récente de ses mémoires
une démonstration d'intelligence de
sérénité qui next qui n'excluait pas la
passion mais aussi l'émotion lorsqu'il
expliquait à bernard pivot pourquoi dans
ce livre volumineux
on ne pouvait trouver qu'une seule fois
le mot bonheur où le mot est employé
c'est la fin des années 30
le bonheur de l'homme le désespoir du
citoyen alors vous me dire qu'un après
les années 30 c'est pas ça c'est pas ça
que le mot bonheur me venait sous la
plume appliqué à une certaine période de
monétique existence et puis très
rapidement il y a eu des événements
différents qui ont donné dix ans une
couleur différente à mon existence et
qui m'a rendu presque impossible emploi
du mot bonheur même lorsque j'avais des
satisfactions cia certains événements
qui vous transforme en profondeur
d'abord la défaite française en 1940 m'a
bouleversé d'une manière permanente
et puis il ya des événements familiaux
que j'ai raconté tout ça me fait autre
que je n'étais auparavant on m'a raconté
que alain après la première guerre
était devenu un homme tout à fait
différent de ce qu'il était auparavant
et je pense que ceux qui ont vécu la
défaite la guerre le génocide
ils le restent au plomb de même quelque
chose qu'il le rend presque impossible
de d'employer le mot bonheur
il est il est possible de vivre
il est possible de surmonter les
souvenirs mais à quelque chose qui une
fois pour toute et frappé raymond aron
78 ans était resté actif jusqu'à son
dernier jour
bruno le dreff nous rappelle la carrière
multiforme qui fut la sienne la vie de
raymond aron et presque indissolublement
liée à celle de jean paul sartre les
voici en 1924 à l'école normale
supérieure de la rue d'ulm leur amitié
survivra mais les divergences
philosophiques et politiques qui les
opposent sont si profondes qu'ils
éviteront tout rencontre pendant plus de
20 ans dès 1933 à l'occasion d'un voyage
à cologne
raymond aron pressent la véritable
nature du nazisme professeur il hésitera
toujours entre une carrière
universitaire et une carrière de
journalisme en 1940 il gagne londres et
devient rédacteur en chef de la revue la
france libre le voici à la libération au
journal combat où il est il y toria
liste
en 1947 il entre au figaro qu'il
quittera trente ans plus tard peu après
la prise de contrôle du journal par
robert hersant
il entre alors au comité éditorial de
l'express le 26 juin 1979 il retrouve
jean paul sartre à l'occasion d'une
campagne en faveur des boat people
le voici les nombreuses activités de
raymond aron lampes ne l'empêchent pas
de mener une carrière universitaire à
sciences po à l'ena à la sorbonne puis
au collège de france où il entre en 1970
une carrière régulièrement ponctuée par
la publication de livres son dernier
écrit ses mémoires viennent juste de
paraître en français serait acceptée en
france
et là-dessus il n'y a pas l'ombre d'un
doute non vraiment à roncq y contribuer
par ses éditoriaux à la critique
politique avait toujours récusé les
étiquettes qu'on lui attribue volontiers
il
disait encore le mois dernier sur
antenne 2 invités d'antenne de midi je
déteste
aujourd'hui par exemple la droite qui
considère que badinter est responsable
d'un détenu en cavale d'avoir tué telle
ou telle personne
ça c'est le genre d'attitude que je
déteste
alors j'ai envie de vous citer une
expression que j'adore qui n'est pas de
moins et le dehors c'est gaddy igas est
il dit être de droite ou être de gauche
c'est d'être hémiplégique
alors quand on me dit si l'un ou l'autre
je dis je refuse d'être hémiplégique
le dernier rapt de sa vie aura été
symbolique témoins engagés dans son
époque au delà des préjugés parfois des
clivages raymond aron a été terrassé
aujourd'hui sur les marches du palais de
justice où il venait de témoigner albert
du roy le spectateur engagé ce titre
donné à un recueil d'entretiens diffusée
sur antenne 2 et la définition que
raymond aron donnait de lui même
spectateurs parce qu'ils aimaient
observer avec une curiosité scrupuleuse
de grands théâtres de l'actualité mais
spectateur engagé parce qu'il finissait
toujours par donner son avis journaliste
il regrettait souvent le confort de
l'activité purement intellectuel
professeur il se sentait mal à l'aise
lorsqu'il ne s'engageait pas
personnellement dans le débat il avait
une fois pour toutes banni le confort
des idéologies clé en main des idées
toutes faites
il est mort lui le gif le juif
antifasciste juste après avoir témoigné
pour un intellectuel accusé de facisme
par un historien israélien
c'est presque un symbole n'oublions pas
qu'il fut jadis l'un des premiers et
dans les colonnes du figaro à dire que
l'algérie française était un non-sens
il fut aussi le premier lui l'économiste
libéral à mettre en garde contre contre
ceux qui l'avaient appelé les
désillusions du progrès il ya une phrase
terrible dont il a toujours souffert
mieux vaut 10 et on avoir tort avec
sartre que raison avec raymond aron le
premier s'est souvent trompé
le second a souvent vu juste mais l'un
était à la mode et l'autre pas du coup
les certitudes de l'ain l'emportait sur
les doutes de
autre le scepticisme c'est toujours une
attitude assez inconfortable
aaron depuis la mort de sartre était
entouré de déférence
il n'avait plus que des disciples et des
admirateurs pour lui c'était un peu une
revanche contre la justice mais je suis
convaincu qu'il jugeait cette déférence
unanime comme il avait jugé toutes les
attitudes excessives avec beaucoup
d'ironie par la voix de son porte-parole
max gallo le gouvernement a rendu
hommage à raymond aron un hommage rendu
au delà des oppositions politiques selon
les termes du communiqué aux travaux du
grand universitaire et à l'exigence
intellectuelle et exprimé ses écrits fin
de citation les réactions sont multiples
bien sûr dans le monde politique
universitaire dans le monde de la presse
aussi hervé brusini vient de rencontrer
quelques-uns des hommes qui à des titres
divers ont été formés par raymond aron
mais je dois dire que je suis très
triste mais que je ne saurais pas en
parler très personnellement comme ça
brûle pourpoint
mais quand j'ai eu cette tristesse quand
clavel est mort quand sartre est mort ce
sont 1 re es de ceux qui ont senti le
sol trembler sous leurs pieds
c'est un des rares qui est saisie et qui
nous reste aujourd'hui qu'ils aient
saisi que hitler aurait pu gagner là
et que daisy claire peuvent gagner la
guerre et toute sa réflexion d'après 45
tourne autour de cela et c'est en france
le premier penseur est un des seuls de
sa génération à avoir pensé la guerre il
a été je crois que moi c'est l'essentiel
en ce qui le concerne il a été un
formidable pédagogue en particulier dans
sûr là aussi deux plans d'une part sur
dans le dialogue avec les intellectuels
qui était engagé avec le communisme et
je crois qu'à peu près avec toutes les
générations y là il a dialogué
autre réaction celle d'alain peyrefitte
qui quelques années après raymond aron
et maintenant éditorialiste au figaro
ceux qui l'avaient d'extraordinaire en
lui c'est que c'était un esprit
universel comme il en existe peu il
avait l'habitude de dire que marx était
le dernier esprit non universitaires il
voulait dire par là que marx
décloisonner toutes les spécialités
nous on pouvait dire ça de lui raymond
aron puisque il embrasse et sous son
regard toutes les spécialités à la fois
que pensez vous qu'il laissera
essentiellement pourquoi que son grand
message
ce sera un message de liberté de
l'esprit c'est à dire de refus de
l'esprit de système il a combattu toute
sa vie l'esprit de système les
idéologies parce que elle plaque une
abstraction sur la réalité vivante dans
notre dernier journal à 23h15 un débat
sur l' influence de rémois rond opposera
le directeur du nouvel observateur jean
daniel au journaliste gilles anquetil
des nouvelles coïncidence le président
mitterrand a aujourd'hui rendu hommage à
un autre grand témoin de son temps
homme politique celui-là pierre
mendès-france
le centre universitaire de la rue de
tolbiac porte désormais son nom
le chef de l'état l'a inaugurée
aujourd'hui en présence de madame
malaise france
nombreuses personnalités politiques
c'est un document exceptionnel que nous
avons voulu privilégier ce soir malgré
les imprévus et les remous de
l'actualité un document qui témoigne
d'une guerre presque oublier celles que
les maquisards afghans continuent de
mener contre le régime de kaboul et
l'occupation soviétique
didier regnier ce véhicule blindé de
fabrication soviétique ouvre la route
un convoi militaire il précède une
vingtaine de camions chargés de soldats
d'armes et de munitions nul ne
s'aventure sur cette route stratégique
sans escorte diot d'un python 150
moudjahidine observe la progression du
convoi
ils sont cachés très bien caché dans la
forêt
c'est là qu'ils ont décidé d'attaquer
dans leur viseur les blindés des forces
de kaboul
le convoi arrive l'embuscade étendu les
moudjahidine tirent des roquettes anti
char sur les 5 premiers blindés
il faut bloquer le reste de la colonne
ensuite ils attaquent les 15 autres
véhicules militaires prises au piège
dans l'impossibilité de ma nouvelle
une quarantaine de soldats afghans et
soviétiques vont mourir dans des
conditions atroces sous les rafales
tirées par les résistants il n'y aura
pas de survivants
cette fois le commando a pu se replier
sans perte car l'armée afghane avait
jugé inutile la couverture du convoi par
des hélicoptères blindés l'attak aura
duré quelques minutes
avant de disparaître dans la montagne
les résistants récupère le matériel
militaire et les objets de valeur puis
il met le feu au véhicule blindé
à quelques mois du quatrième
anniversaire de cette guerre un peu
oublié ces images rappellent que les
soviétiques contrôle difficilement la
situation
même sur les grands axes
revenons à l'actualité en france qui est
d'abord économique ce soir le ministre
de l'économie et des finances a
réaffirmé aujourd'hui que malgré la
poussée des prix en septembre son
objectif reste le même réduire
l'infection pour que le taux l'an
prochain ne soit pas supérieure à 5%
monsieur de l'or a cependant a aussi
écarté pour l'instant at il dit tout
blocage des prix il a aussi laissé
prévoir une aggravation du chômage
certaine mutation industrielle étant
indispensable affrontements et confusion
dans les deux usines rouennaise de la
chapelle darblay que se disputent le
personnel non grévistes et la cgt à
grand-couronne le personnel non gréviste
a investi les locaux et le travail a
repris à saint-etienne du rouvray dans
l'autre usine ils n'ont pas réussi et la
cgt continue d'occuper les lieux quand
une pertuis les fonds de police ont
gardé toute la journée l'entrée de
lusine de cran pour angle mais les
rassemblements n'ont été que verbaux dès
ce matin l'ensemble du personnel
favorable au plan par enhco pénètre dans
l'établissement
dehors reste le petit groupe de cgpi qui
avaient été évacués dans la nuit par les
noms de lévis
la cgt parle de commandos armés et
masqués à quelques kilomètres de là à
saint-etienne du rouvray le personnel
qui s'était présenté accompagné d'un
huissier a pu dans un premier temps
rentrer dans nos usines
il était peu à peu repoussé hors de
l'établissement à 9h30 la qualité
occupait de nouveau les bleus une
ordonnance d'expulsion pourrait être
prononcée au ministère de l'industrie on
se contente de dire qu'en ne
fonctionnant qu'en partie la chapelle
darblay pourrait encore perdre des
clients et donc aggraver sa situation
financière après demain mercredi
élections élections à la sécurité
sociale
trente millions d'électeurs vont pour la
première fois désigné leurs
représentants aux caisses d'assurance
maladie et aux caisses d'allocations
familiales
parmi eux la clientèle classique des
syndicats les salariés mais aussi deux
autres catégories d'électeurs
les jeunes et les retraités que
représente pour eux la sécurité sociale
l'enquète de martine gilson et gilbert
usant c'est quoi la sécurité sociale
pour vous
on sent vraiment fallait le faire avant
le jeu ne pas savoir où ils nous ont
donné des papiers à envoyer des papiers
et être papier on sait même pas ce que
c'est votez votez ci voté ça on sait pas
ce que ça hein
ils les ont 16 ans mercredi comme tous
les assurés de plus de 16 ans ils ont
leur mot à dire même si la sécu comme
ils disent ils ne connaissent pas la
paperie savais pas trop ce que c'est la
sécu mais vous allez voter je voter
quand même
joachim va voter mais pour qui nouvelle
clientèle des syndicats les jeunes sont
aussi pour les mêmes syndicats
la grande inconnue du scrutin
irène et pierre lemoine e coule des
jours de retraités tranquille depuis
plus de dix ans elle était employée de
bureau
il était cheminot la sécurité sociale
pour eux ça compte
bien c'est d'abord et d'administration
c'est aussi une parente une amie s'était
laissée comme dit bien son nom elle est
sécurisante une parente pourquoi là
parce qu'on a confiance en elle comme
comme on a confiance à une part entre
une amie quand on a notre âge quand on a
connu dans le temps à l'époque avant
1900 n'y avait pas de sécurité sociale
ou une touche et rien ou les malades ne
toucher à rien les parents pour les
enfants le mari ou sa femme souvent bien
que dans certaines administrations mari
pouvait être couvert mais ciel de marie
la famille était pas alors que
maintenant tout le monde est tout de
même protégé par la sécurité sociale
besser c'est une grosse affaire c'est un
grand réconfort moral pour ses clients
nous le même avis vous ben certainement
pas parce qu'on ne va pas expliquer pour
la sécurité sociale c'était lorsque ont
pour beaucoup de choses que de cette
jeunesse de joseph bachelet chantant par
seulement les jeunes je ne sais pas et
je ne leur explique pas mais les jeunes
j'irai des gens même les personnes déjà
20 s'agit pas d'un certain âge mais d'un
âge
enfin plus grand quoi les grandes
personnes ce qu'on appelle les actifs
par exemple mais beaucoup d'actifs
actuellement ne savent pas du tout la
sécurité sociale pour les ccc c'est
quelque chose qui auquel on doit c'est
le motive bien toujours mais il se doit
sur les aides que ce qu'elles étaient
soit alimenté alors pour les alimenter
une grande l'argent ou plantes tout bien
sûr il faut que les jeunes payent il
faut également que les autres payent les
élections ça vous intéresse ballet ou
bien sûr que ça nous intéresse société
élections c'est bien si ça nous
intéresse à savoir les retraités ils
seront 5 millions 500 mille les jeunes
on ignore leur nombre exact
deux inconnues de taille dans un scrutin
qui va déterminer pour six ans la
représentativité des syndicats 51,29 %
des voix pour le rpr patrick devedjian
48,71 pour le communiste andré aubry la
gauche a perdu
à antony une nouvelle élection
municipale partielle sa troisième
défaite dans une ville de plus de 30000
habitants réaction du nouveau maire nous
serons les élus de tous les antonien
sans discrimination réaction du
porte-parole du parti socialiste
bertrand delanoë
le résultat d'anthony marque une
nouvelle étape des convergences de la
droite et de l'extrême droite
pas de réaction officielle encore du
parti communiste
c'est par un appel à la relance de la
construction européenne est une
dénonciation de la passivité de l'europe
face à la menace militaire soviétique
pour reprendre les termes qu'il vient
d'employés que le président du rpr
jacques chirac qui est ce soir à bonn
vient de commencer un discours devant la
fondation farha à de nos aïeux chirac a
eu cet après-midi un long entretien avec
le chancelier elle nous folle sur le
problème des euromissiles et du
pacifisme dans la vague des
manifestations organisées pendant une
semaine par les mouvements pacifistes
allemands 38 femmes ont défilé
aujourd'hui dans plusieurs villes du
pays
le chancelier kohl réagi fermement aux
défis que les pacifistes lance à son
gouvernement la fac ne pas céder au
chantage soviétique à l'image des alliés
jadis confronté au totalitarisme
hitlérien pour helmut kohl l'histoire ne
se répète pas mais la situation est
comparable à celle de 38 chamberlain et
daladier se sont rendus à munich pour
rencontrer hitler et mussolini en
croyant servir la paix daladier avant
son départ de paris pour munich s'est vu
conseiller la modération pas son chef
d'état major le général gamelin qui lui
demandaient les signer
en clair on a cédé à hitler aujourd'hui
le chancelier kohl annonce donc la
couleur celle de pershing américaine
encore en usine aux états unis mais dont
la mise en batterie début décembre
prochain semble désormais inéluctable
car les négociations de genève sont dans
l'impasse
les soviétiques ne bouge plus d'un
millimètre il persiste à vouloir compter
les forces de dissuasion française et
anglaise dans la balance euros
stratégique à vienne en district gagne
cher le ministre des affaires étrangères
de bonn a tenté de limiter les dégâts
d'assurer moscou
ou et andreï gromyko de sa bonne volonté
dans la perspective du refroidissement
et des coups de tabac éventuelle de
l'après pershing
pour toutes ces raisons et en ce début
de semaine le front pacifiste n'en est
que plus ample plus déterminés il y à
une union sacrée entre pacifiste pure à
la gandhi et d'autres groupes soutenus
par les églises et les partis politiques
on en oublie que sans la logistique et
l'organisation indispensable de l'ale
communiste assez minoritaire du
mouvement il faut le dire ces
manifestations sombrerait dans le
désordre dans l'intervalle après un an
d'opposition seulement le parti
social-démocrate de willebrand et à
contrario des opinions de helmut schmidt
le spd a rejoint les rangs des
contestataires
la preuve d'un mouvement profond durable
le ministre des affaires étrangères
soviétique andreï gromyko est
aujourd'hui dans l'autre allemagne à
berlin est une visite d'amitié selon le
terme consacré qui est l'occasion d'une
concertation avec les dirigeants
est-allemands sur les euromissiles un
soldat libanais tués aujourd'hui à
beyrouth deux autres blessés les marines
américains restent en état d' alerte les
tirs contre leurs positions près de
l'aéroport de la capitale libanaise ont
repris ce matin hier je vous le rappelle
un soldat américain a été tué cinq
autres glissé le président reagan a
cependant réaffirmé aujourd'hui sa
détermination à maintenir le contingent
américain ou libre une confirmation mais
même s'il ne s'agit pas encore d'une
décision définitive et officielle ronald
reagan a autorisé aujourd'hui la
création du comité
regan bush 84 un comité qui orchestrera
la campagne du président et du
vice-président américain pour les
prochaines élections présidentielles aux
états unis le prix nobel d'économie 1983
a été attribué à un américain d'origine
française le professeur gérard debreu
c'est un théoricien de l'économie de
marché
a marseille la petite corinne dit
il en a été rendu aujourd'hui à la
justice par sa grand-mère qui l'a cachée
jusqu'ici son grand père qui avait
préféré aller en prison plutôt que de se
séparer de l'enfant va être très
prochainement remise en liberté
la fillette a été confiée provisoirement
à une institution spécialisée
en attendant que les passions familiale
se calme c'est un français peu commun
qui vient de s'ouvrir à lyon le français
235 commerçants coupable d'escroquerie à
la loterie nationale
il avait trouvé dans les années 73 76
ans moyen astucieux pour blanchir de
l'argent non déclaré à lyon paul
lefebvre comme une grande fille toute
simple en somme naïve principes de base
elle confiait des gens hors soupçon
l'impression et la distribution de ces
billets
ces genres soupçons ont droit à des
pourcentages plus les billets gagnants
nous réclamer la loterie elle même
devant pas tous ses billets ce qui
réduit évidemment les risques de
paiement ils sont 135 aujourd'hui devant
le tribunal de lyon être les victimes
entre guillemets d'une idée géniale
la voici pour éviter les droits de
succession pour éviter les taxes sur le
travail au noir pour éviter etc
en somme les ennuis et la curiosité du
fisc soit ont racheté des billets
gagnants
revenu d'un imposé soit on s'arrangeait
pour obtenir moyennant redevance en
sous-main des attestations de gains à la
loterie
en somme on blanchissez des capitaux des
capitaux clandestins la loterie n'y peut
rien c'est à faire de concessions dans
les milieux textile du sentier la
république à paris
la filière était bien connu tellement
connu qu'on l'a découverte et déjà le
fisc avant ces trois semaines de procès
est passé avec ses redressement en forme
de purgatoire ce qui était que sorte
moral aujourd'hui ils disent tous ses
135 on a été tenté et oui une très bonne
nouvelle pour les amateurs de football
le match paris saint germain juventus de
turin sera retransmis en direct sur
antenne 2 mercredi soir à 20h30 accalmie
dans la tempête après avoir été reporté
plusieurs fois c'est finalement à 14h
cet après midi qu'a été donné le départ
de la course de voile la baule dakar
vat trois voiliers sont partis 23 et non
25 car deux bateaux sont entrés en
collision
quelques minutes après le départ il
s'agit de deux des favoris le trimaran
de florence arthaud est le catamaran de
loïc caradec les deux voiliers ont dû
rentrer au port pour réparer les dégâts
gilles cozanet mais rebelle et bon vent
après la tempête je n'ai pas encore le
calme mais des conditions idéales pour
un départ de course au large à 14h01 il
était donc 23 dont 22 multicoques un
seul monocoque pour prendre le départ de
la seule course au large qui ne traverse
pas l'atlantique la seule aussi qu'à des
points de passage obligatoire aux açores
canaries au cap vert ce qui en fait un
rallye
là où une transat est encore un raid est
une aventure une course en équipage où
l'on retrouve tous les ténors français
marc pajot et son catamaran elf
aquitaine
eugène riguidel aussi avec saul williams
aura son trimaran géant de 27 mètres de
long qui dispose en plus d'un équipage
de choc où l'on retrouve notamment à la
gabelle et yves pajot le frère de marc
vainqueur de l'admiral's cup cet été ces
deux bateaux sont les deux grands
outsiders de l'épreuve
mais le favori qui a d'ailleurs gagné la
régate préliminaire organisé dans la
baie de la baule c'est le jet services
de patrick morvan un catamaran de 18
mètres très léger et à l'impressionnant
potentiel de vitesse
une suite inattendue au grand prix
d'afrique du sud de formule 1 albert
ferrasse le président de la fédération
française de rugby se fâche
en effet le 6 avril dernier il se voyait
interdire par le gouvernement une
tournée en afrique du sud avec le quinze
de france de mauvaise grâce vous en
souvenez il acceptait cette interdiction
après avoir rencontré le chef de l'état
mais cet après-midi albert ferrasse est
revenu sur sa décision
le quinze de france ira en afrique du
sud que cela plaise ou non at il dit ces
explications à nos confrères de faire
trois nous reviendrons rhinau et
rose-marie de suite pourquoi moi j'ai
tout à fait d'accord les automobilistes
impliqués descend tout ça et là bas
c'est très bien au contraire ça me ravit
il ya l'humain est elle parfaitement au
comptant de voir ces gens là et surtout
peut-être championne du monde n'a pas
marché je regarde pour eux c'était une
bonne chose
ap dallas et pour moi que ça nous fait
mal que personne ne réagit parce que
quand nous sommes pas allés en afrique
du sud
bon c'est après une entrevue et le
brillant arrêt public la raison d'état
avait prévalu
mais karl de quatre joueurs français
sont partis là bas pour jouer un match
et que j'ai eu tout un tas de
protestations de tous les comités anti
raciste de monsieur moustache mon
homologue fsgt qui siège à viborg
olympique nelson paillou mon ami l'a
prouvé et tout un tas jamais un ministre
et c'est pas madame avis qu a protesté
et qui va fustigé encore jeune il avait
fustigé
or le true games n'a pour le moment pas
de réaction officielle ni du côté du
ministère des sports ni du côté du quai
d'orsay
un mot du temps maintenant avec un alain
gillot-pétré très en beauté tout en se
les y est oui mais ça va pas durer
longtemps avec ce qui nous arrive dessus
en tout cas pour le nord du pays
le nord il sera à carreaux et le sud
sera ok regardez la photo satellite et
où tu te comprendre pourquoi nous avons
un anticyclone et une dépression la
photo satellite wind ont pris voilà à
l'anticyclone ici on voit très bien
voyez pas de nuages qui poussent par ici
mais une dépression là qui poussent par
là la dépression va passer au nord et
l'anticyclone va rester au sud ça lui
donne pour demain la carte la carte
maintenant voilà sur la moitié nord donc
des nuages de la plus quelques petits
rayons de soleil et du vent d'ouest qui
se renforcera de nouveau
mange sans atteindre toutefois la
tempête tandis qu'au sud plus vous irez
vers le sud plus il fera beau et
notamment militaires année grâce au
mistral qui persistera le baromètre sera
en hausse le thermomètre ne bougera pas
la main de 12 degrés au nord est à 20
degrés en méditerranée 12 à 16 sur la
moitié nord 15 à 20 c sur la moitié sud
ça n'est vraiment pas beaucoup c'est en
dessous des normes
on sera demain quand même mardi 18
octobre quatre minutes de soleil en
moins excusez du peu levé 7h16 coup j'ai
une couche et 17 heures 55 sél a fallu
qu'elle patron des pavés les médecins à
23h15 hervé claude vous présentera notre
dernier journal de ma 12h40 cinquantaine
de midi avec daniel bilalian 18h30 c'est
la vie j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain à 20 heures
très bonne soirée
à